[Laughter]
every day just a little closer to being
the 4th handsome brother and I think the
long-lost sister of Macaulay and Kieran
Culkin mmm dip fondue ah the Oscars
happen so you know it has to happen
doesn't have to I have free will
regardless of what many of you believe
but it's gonna happen we're doing the
Oscars fashion review y'all also you
can't really tell but in the Heaven's
Gate scape but I care there is a goose
okay the Oscars happened over the
weekend I sort of watched them but I
went to an all-female Oscar viewing
party at made me Hart's place and the
majority of my time was spent yeah
that's really the only part of the
Oscars I remembered seeing which is
great it means that all of my fashion
review takes on this will be very fresh
fresh and me should not go insane as
fresh is like day-old produce that's
been sitting on a countertop
unrefrigerated let's get into it I went
on Twitter and asked you guys are some
of your favorite looks I tried to
incorporate them into this video as
always I will miss people I will
mispronounce people I will missy elliott
skip it and reverse it in the editing is
it worth it let me work it out with my
therapist Jennifer can't wait to our
next session here we go oh boy first of
all give me the benefit of the goddamn
doubt that was the original name of no
doubt but goddamn doubt if there is a
ton of beautiful wonderful shiny happy
seemingly people that attended the
Oscars so there's a lot to get through
let's see if like me driving my car in
traffic if we could put a dent in it
Lady Gaga I mean showstopper Wow
Cinderella has two hip tumors and
decided that she's gone gone for the
night is beautiful
he's wearing the Titanic necklace also
of those hip pad great teeny little
shelves to rest our drinks at the after
parties when you're trying to make small
talk with everyone about how great you
are
Cooper is that by her hips are swollen
as if they both got into the deep end
that's what she said
gross cube laura dern picking up classic
Hollywood elegance
she looks beautiful this does look like
an 80s prom dress but the color is
fantastic on her and I love this woman
to the core she just ages like a fine
Merlot wine that's what she's doing she
you're being an actual bottle of Merlot
wine how dare you Dern God darn it okay
okay cute Elsie Fisher I love this so
much
Elsie style rules I wearing a bolo tie
though oh I love this so much she wears
these most incredible suits to all these
award shows and I love it you are like a
little Janelle Monae meets Troye Sivan
meets like one of the people from the
baby-sitters club and I just love it so
much ah and you're just nice q Kacey
Musgraves Wow oh my Anna a hardware
store cuz that's a lot of tulle KC you
must put me in a grave
it's that jump me this is like southern
belle meets my super sweet 16 and also
itchy
it's your armpits maybe that's like the
new cool thing for 2019 she's doing an
itch stitch yeah my microphone on ooh
joke's on you it is Olivia Colman okay
okay I said okay
sorry my mouth got excited okay I don't
know who this woman was but I saw her
win Best Actress I think in her speech
was amazing and humble and sweet and
charming and lovely and I just thought
she was absolutely darling and wonderful
and darling is a weird term to use for
your elder I respected the Scout of her
and this dressed cool I know I should
know who she is I know I know I know
I know you must be new here I don't know
anything but I do know that I genuinely
without knowing this woman loved her
very much from her speech it felt very
genuine and authentic and she just felt
so sweet I want her to be in my family
how can I adopt an elder leave a comment
down below yeah Chris Evans he stands
like he's going to beat the show I just
heard volume on Twitter recently he is
saying he's been doing some lifts in the
gym because his arms have been dragging
people left and right and I'm here for a
baby blue velvet tuxedo look at you go
ah I hope you
your CPR certification cuz I'm drowning
in feels right now
it's cute Jennifer Lopez oh speaking of
like Marvel action hero you look like
you're literally transforming into some
sort of light in scorpion scorpan test
score Burton look I just made up a
superhero anyone from Marvel or DC one
should develop score Burton with me
starring Jennifer Lopez which she gets
ready for award shows she morphs into a
tin foil scorpion and she doesn't fight
crime or save anyone she just looks
ageless and beautiful you we could work
shopping I'm a stone you look adorable
she could do no wrong she looks
beautiful it's futuristic and also looks
a little bit like my air conditioning
filters when I remove them and have to
replace them yeah it's Sarah Paulson wow
wow wow this looks comfortable and
confusing this is like a full-body satin
snood this is nuts
what is it how is this what is happening
I don't even know what the how is this
cool wedding cake yeah it's chadwick
boseman always looks fantastic I love
everything he wears he's always having a
great time he's being his best self I
love all of this I don't know what else
to say my hands can't stop doing this
I guess now he makes me play a tiny
invisible accordion when I see Angela
Bassett oh my god you look like Angela
gift basket yeah this looks insanely
beautiful although it looks fantastic
and fits you like a bow on a brand new
Honda Civic that someone bought for
their kids graduation Jew Chili's Theron
or Alison Brie's older half-sister
choice around always looks stunning this
is very like dynasty designing women'
esque meets madmen Cruella De Vil I
don't know why I'm intimidated I'm kind
of scared but like I kind of trust you
there's something demure and hard about
this at the same time but Cadbury egg so
you know the insides will stop the
stupid the outsides hard and like
complicated to get through and like mmm
you know if you want to take it all on
oh this got away from me I don't know
what thank you brie Larson Captain
Marvel well
I marvel at this you look stunning you
look like you and Jennifer lópez's went
in for the same corporate enroll post
coveted upcoming Marvel or DC role that
we will see in 2020 and you know it's a
tight race or who's gonna get the part
this is where we're at now this is what
I'm gonna kick in my life to you I'm
close Glenn get closer I just want you
to swaddle me and all of that gold
fabric and make me feel like a safe
giant baby that's all I gotta say about
that cute Amy Poehler I love this outfit
so much is she the mother of Elsie
Fisher has anyone done a DNA test can we
do a 23andme are they related that what
is going on I love this so much I want
to wear this to every single red-carpet
event I ever have to go to in my entire
life United so many airplane bottles of
booze and so many snacks I'm so just
cute Tina Fey Oh God so elegant you look
like a delicate wave just washed ashore
I don't know if I'm gross saying that
this looks very regal very elegant you
can probably fart off tonight long in
that and no one will ever smell it it's
gonna stay trapped cute Maya Rudolph
never mind you can fart all night in
that and that's gonna stay trapped it's
like she took Tina and Amy up a notch
and said you guys were in like a lot of
fabric I beg to differ
I'm bringing the whole [ __ ] mood store
with me that's a that's a Project Runway
joke swatch
Lisa Bonet and Aquaman I forget his name
they look like muted very 70s Pixies I
mean they look cool as heck wearing a
scrunchie around his wrists because they
can do whatever they want
I might have very strong opinions about
the movie Aquaman under this might get
weird podcasts that doesn't mean I don't
think that they're the coolest humans in
the universe she looks like she's caught
in a net by Aquaman and he looks like
he's the third cooler adult brother of
the Dumb and Dumber franchise when they
have sex it must be so cool
this is inappropriate now cute shangela
oh my gosh so many of you tweeted me
photos of shangela and yes Henny this is
a Luke your body looks incredible this
dress is beautiful your skin looks
stunning your hair looks or just I don't
even know what to say this is like a
dump this is some Cinderella [ __ ]
right now and I love it so much it makes
me mad yeah goose thank you for agreeing
with me cute selma blair how many of you
wanted me to review summer blair this
was her first public appearance since
she announced that she spent all going
with ms four years and she looked sking
stunning I have no jokes to make about
it one because that's wildly insensitive
and she looks beautiful and this is
incredibly brave and wonderful and
amazing of her to even go to an event
like this let alone look this fantastic
also this photo is beautiful cute Billy
Porter my god I really support her me
because I don't deserve to live in the
same country as you because this is
seeking liberty and justice for all and
the confidence in your face and body to
wear this who if I ever get married I
just want this on my cake topper just
Billy Porter not my husband and myself
just really important exactly like this
please cute Marie Kondo touch it once
we're back my battery died cuz I guess
my video did not bring Marie Kondo joy
but her outfit brings me joy IQ alright
that's it for an Oscars fashion review I
again I'm sorry if I missed a lot of
people that you wanted me to talk about
but I tried to cover as many as I could
without getting bored myself in this
video if you liked this video give it a
thumbs up hit the bell turn the bells
ring the bells all of the bells and
don't forget to subscribe to this
YouTube channel I make videos other than
that I don't know
- was there and a lot of you reminded me
thank you so much she's got palm fronds
all over her it makes you want to
high-five her and be palm friends bye